tamar is now getting the proper help
that she needs
nene leakes took to instagram live
saturday
to give fans an update on tamar braxton
amid her reported hospitalization
with tamar uh tamar
and myself we have been dealing with a
lot of different
issues um and
i was trying to be her support system
and she was being my support system
nene continued by reiterating a similar
message
to what she wrote on her instagram post
the day before
a message about the downside that comes
with being viewed as quote
a strong person i have dealt with
so much lately and i just want to say
the black lives matter movement has
helped me in in so many ways
if i told you the way that i was being
treated
in a certain way you would not probably
believe it
and same thing with tamar you just
probably would not believe it because
you would think
that because we are so strong that why
would we allow such a thing to happen
but sometimes when you in certain
situations you don't have any other
choice
the real housewives of atlanta star
didn't share any details about what
tamar is personally
going through but she did say that
people would soon
find out she has been hurting
and
and and we've all dealt with a lot of
stuff lately just
dealt with a really really tremendous
amount of
stress when we both pray and we both
believe in the lord but
um you know sometimes you need i'm human
and i need
i would like to have a friend that i can
lean on and i can trust them
and really trust them nene made it a
point to thank her fans
for their support please continue to
support you don't understand how
difficult it is
for a lot of us uh to speak out
and and and get the help that we need
the reality star's comments about tamar
come after it was reported by the blast
that she was found unresponsive on
thursday
by her boyfriend david especial at the
ritz-carlton residences
in los angeles a spokesperson for the
los angeles fire department
told e.t that they responded to a call
at 9
57 p.m on thursday night for a reported
unconscious adult female they dropped
the woman
off at the hospital and said that they
had no information
on her current condition her rep told
the blast quote
tamar had a very tough and emotional day
more information will be coming in the
next few days
please pray for her and i don't want any
drama you know i mean i'm living my best
life
when et spoke with tamar back in may she
seemed to be in good spirits
enjoying quarantine i'm eating my
weights
you know and i'm having fun with my
boyfriend and great time with my kid and
i have
absolutely no worries and i have this
amazing show on vh1 which is
a dream job for me a dream situation and
i am just getting a really really happy
good place
you